the old-school conservationists laughed
at us they said it's never gonna work
I'm 25 years old and one of the black
mambas I'm looking other blood numbers
and approaching unit
they're always very very shy at the
beginning and then they get a six-week
training course and that's taking them
through a ready procedures Fitness how
to use the equipment two weeks they'll
go off in a bush somewhere and they have
to survive by themselves but in my own
chocolate Axl swimming was to learn
about the behaviors of the animals the
wild ones so when we come across them we
know what to do I told myself that I
have to do it we haven't had a single
profile - huh - no so now I'm used to it
and it was protecting the nature itself
always always driven me from when I was
young to protect the environment when I
come out of the training made very
different people
my favorite part of my job is patrolling
the fence go around the sleeping was
less every hour I called him to check on
them we didn't find something suspicious
we call for backup
usually we're not using weapons where
eyes and ears of the reserves we are
doing it differently this one poaching
is bigger than guns and bullets
and we are going through schools to
teach children's about the environment
about how to protect the animals system
that is not good to kill an animal that
will like you because we didn't have
that opportunity there was no one to
tell us about the life of animals
and now visiting is 668 learners that
we're reaching awareness isn't the main
objective to be a black member it means
we are tough and strong young ladies who
can work in the bushes without no fear I
know that I'm helping the animals out
there as a black member I feel proud in
a community when I'm wearing mine and
people when they look up at me they see
a euro if we lost around I than we
failed we mark our success on the amount
of time that we've gone without losing
within one year they've brought down
snaring by 86 percent and there'd been
no rhino poaching in this region either
that was proof enough to everybody that
it's working now that we are having big
numbers
there's decrease of portions we are
doing a difference I always knew that it
would work we just didn't realize how
quickly it was going to take
and how quickly the results please shut
you